одеса ​​ось на мій погляд залишається з
міст мільйонників що знаходяться в
при фронтовій зоні найбільш мирним і
спокійним містом життя повертається в
якийсь
нормальність напевно якусь довоєнну
якщо це можна звичайно говорити в таких
умовах але як це вдається я можу
сказати що тільки завдяки нашим
збройним силам України та завдяки
тим і героїчної оборони
збройними силами та
підрозділами територіальної оборони
які стримується 11 ск окупантів на
рубежі миколаєва Вознесенська та
фактично одеський фронт знаходиться
сьогодні там лише завдяки стримуванню
наступальних дій
противника вони не рухаються убік
одеси це перше друге що стосується
морської операції також завдяки
нашим збройним силам та
поразка знайшли удар по крейсера москва
який затонув
сьогодні ми говоримо і про більш спокійну
ситуації на морі про те, що чекати
настання або здати висадки десанту
сьогодні з боку моря
ми вона може статися, але ймовірність її
значно менше
без прикриття крейсера москва вся
угруповання морське угруповання
Російська федерація військ противника
окупанта вона сьогодні суттєво
знизилася щодо
можливого нападу з боку
придністров'я також за оцінками
збройних сил за оцінками експертів
говоримо про те, що силою зріз там не
особливо й достатньо для розвитку
наступальної самостійної
наступальної операції якщо це все
діятиме як єдиний орган
наступ тобто Миколи Вознесенська
моря та придністров'я це ще якось
можна розглядати але самостійно
рацію та розвивати наступальні
дії з кордону придністров'я це
сьогодні малоймовірно готове місто чи
готується не місто військові з якими ви
набагато більше ніж ми спілкуємося або
спілкуєтеся до того, що ракетні удари
стануть інтенсивнішими і що місто чекає
доля якщо в нього болить а харкова
Котрий
ну під градом сидить і не знаю примари
від якихось не знаєте я
можливо ще там місяць-два тому можна
більше взагалі вважав би що це
фантастика щодо вже два місяці
більше двох місяців війні
я вже
трохи нічого не можу пояснити для
себе наприклад навіщо потрібна варварська
раттак руйнувати харків навіщо потрібна
спальний район у харкові просто
знищити загалом навіщо це яку мету
яка то як може виправдати будь-яка
спеціальна операція з діана civic ації
деталізації до чого тут окремо син
аплікація металізація до руйнування
цілого житлового кварталу
прекрасного міста харків тому я
чому вам так і відповідаючи на це питання
у цьому я не знаю що у нього лови якщо у
них взагалі щось у думці якісь
вони мені здається таке що вони наробили
цих ракет і ось у них є план
вибудували припустимо в день 20 ракет
вони їх куляють їх або вибачте за таке
слово посилати ці ракети якимись
своїм планам не знаю чи є у них ці
плани руйнують інфраструктуру українську
руйнують міста ось таке тому я не
можу виключити, що завтра їм не вдарить
щось на думку і не почну не почнуть
бомбити або обстрілювати ракетами місто
одесу це складно передбачити
те, що сьогодні творить кажучи or fax
цілої країни до коропами масових
заходах ви багато років ходили у
перших рядах 9 травня в одесі
традиційними широко відзначають свято
вашого можуть навіть незважаючи на candida
цей зменшують освіту я пам'ятаю як
раз був ізи не щоб ви створили. але
по-перше я вам скажу і не знаю знаєте
як я ніколи не намагався бути такий
дотримувався політичної кон'юнктури
сьогодні ти одне завтра і те й інше я з
повагою ставився ставлюсь і буду
ставитися до історії
до історії Другої світової війни та в скарбі
одеси міста-героя у перемогу над
нацизмом фашизм тому я особливо
абсолютно усвідомлено як ви сказали в
перших рядах їжу та їжу 9 травня покладають
квіти тим захисником одеси тим хто
обороняли і хто її звільняв їх
вдячний за те, що вони звільнили
одесу весь світ від нацизму та фашизму в
цього року ситуація досить складна з
однієї сторони хотілося б все-таки щоб
ми традиційно поклали квіти що ми
традиційно
віддали данину пам'яті тим хто гідний цього
з іншого боку
ми не впевнені в тому, що саме в цей
день як і в інші дні як ось будуємо і
ті, хто сьогодні куповано частково
купер час на окупованій
території напав на нашу країну не
захоче це відзначити якось по-своєму
цей день у них уже розумієте
дійсно жахливі речі 23 числа в ніч
перед Великоднем було завдано удару і загинули
вісім понесли у 8 життя ракета
російська в тому числі тримісячна
дівчатка
це православне свято вони ж кажуть
про те, що Росія православна країна тим
не менше не завадило 23 нанести ракетний
удар цинічно по житловому будинку на 2 травня
завдати ракетного удару тому ми
та відповідальний за безпеку
а я я в тому числі відповідальним за
безпека мешканців нашого міста
тому складно сказати сьогодні ми в
роздумах думаємо як нам
дотриматися як я вже складу цю непошану
до того ж час, безпечніше сьогодні живуть
одеситів можливих і провокацій та
нанесення різних ударів
артилерійських ракетних авіаударів для
когось війна зливалася в один довгий
день на когось вона складається з до для
вас о 23 час які коментарі 3
або навіть і 2 наступним змінили
подання у цій війні
ви знаєте я
мені взагалі дуже складно людям я не
вважаю себе там літнім літнім
людиною в жодному разі але в першу
черга для людей похилого віку для людей
старшого покоління
для людей, народжених у радянському союзі
це боєм набагато більша аудиторія
взагалі це складно дуже сприймати те
що зараз відбувається це що
коли я говорю деякі речі я говорю
їх свідомо але коли я кажу я завжди
не міг уявити і що я колись у
життя скажу ці речі що я скажу що
сьогодні російська федерація
країна-агресор що сьогодні вони вбивають
наших людей, що сьогодні не втратили ці
людське обличчя повністю що сьогодні
напередодні 9 травня я не можу сьогодні
сказати що російський солдат і поставити
знак рівності між радянським солдатам
тому що радянський солдат звільняв
Європу радянських солдатів боровся з
фашизмом і нацизмом, а сьогодні російська
солдат російський офіцер стріляють на мою
місту вбиває моїх земляків не маючи на
то причини так само як чинили
сорок першому році гітлерівська Німеччина
розумієте я кажу це та все ще вчора я не
міг собі уявити, що таке може
бути а сьогодні це факт і збоку
накопичується певне котиться
певна війна хвиля
новий вид не декомунізації навіть це
перрі перейменування багатьох топонімів
пов'язаних з російською культурою в Києві
готується перейменувати станцію лева
товстого наприклад вулицю пушкінську в
одесі цих топонімів дуже багато одеса
сильно була пов'язана з російською культурою
багато років і я пам'ятаю, як проходила тут
перша хвиля декомунізації достатньо
конфліктний у 2015 році переживе світ
готується не одеситам до
до нової хвилі і взагалі чи залишиться в
одесі місце для російської культури після
всього цього після цієї війни це дуже
важке питання
складне питання для нас для всіх
але
[музика]
сьогодні
російської федерації його і цим лідером
припустимо на допущений на мій погляд
колосальна колосальна помилка в
відношенні і своєї культури та свого
народу і всі свого місця на
вищому пострадянському просторі
буквально поряд з мерією ви бачили гармату
трофейна трофейна гармата з регата тигр
яка колись стріляла зрозуміти
[музика]
так от там була одна з табличок
написано слава російському назовні та
захисником одеси та
його ніхто не чіпав одесити вловили
зброя яка захистила наш дім
це не було слова там російській людині
захистившим у слава російській ось така
фраза була ми
міняємо ці таблички вибираємо цю тому
що сьогодні це звучить дуже
так знайти різко-різко і просто але люди
не сприймають за абсурд треба правильно
знову 0 це абсурдно виглядає коли
росіяни стріляють по нам ракетами ми
пишемо славу російській пики але це все
зробив владимир путін і як і багато
речі тому що сьогодні все що стосується
російської на ці підсвідомо ловиш
саме думки, що навіть вже по-іншому
сприймаєш і тих талановитих цього
ось це талановитих акторів і
талановитих якихось не знаю
представники культури різних по
різним напрямкам
через росію, які сьогодні мовчать
начебто утворені начебто культурні
люди і не дурні та грамотні
то купу мовчите ви що не бачите що
тут
війна ви не знаєте ви може бути десь
якось вони говорять та що в Росії там
100 кілометрів від Москви або 200 там уже
ніхто і там телевізорів немає у них теж
мислитель вони нічого не знають що
відбувається їм сказали не всі повірили
побігли але почекайте хвилиночку а інші
люди які сьогодні мають
можливості мають родичів за
кордоном у Німеччині велика діаспора
в одного стадіонних штатах Америки вони не
знають це не знають це
така ви самі про що ви хочете яку
реакцію ви хочете сьогодні тут якщо ви
заохочуєте з вашої мовчазної згоди
то все відбувається в період
війни жорстокої війни сьогодні звичайно
деякі рішення можуть прийматися та
так досить емоційно емоційно
тому
хотілося б щоб цього не було втрачено
біля мерії також стоїть пам'ятник пушкіну
але
що цікаво що цей пам'ятник
був споруджений на зібрані гроші
одеситами одесити колись зібрали
гроші пушкін досвідченого діти це наша
історія звичайно якщо буде прийнято
рішення про такі такі процеси
це буде достатньо, щоб болісно але
фактично ми
почнемо нову якусь абсолютно сторінку
історії
абсолютно нового
кажучи сторінках історії ми з вами
востаннє я зніму я ще залишається для
невеликого блоку питань час ми з
вами востаннє бачились києві в суді
проти вас були виведені ти достатньо
слова та звинувачення у тому числі викликав його
не і міського бюджетів розкрадання
міської землі що зараз з цими
кримінальними справами судами про це все
забули ну напевно не ви
це ні чому не тільки я йому теж не
забуваю теж не забуваю знаєте я скажу
коли мені запитав одне з
журналістів говорить про те, що він щастя
з можливість там не те що можливість
що хто бере участь активно протистоїть
агресії що може бути там якось
закритий справи або інше я
відповідав Іван сьогодні відповім і ні в якому
випадку не хочу щоб моя справа була
закрито за якимись пом'якшуючими
обставиною
я хочу і вимагає для того, щоб суд
відбувся я отримав виправдувальний
вирок а я в ньому впевнений на сто
відсотків був впевнений коли це сталося
у сімнадцятому вісімнадцятому році перше
підозра і як і в інших
тому готовий відповісти на ці запитання
відповідати і маю надії сьогодні польша
з'явилася що може бути
суд буде вже не таким політизовано і
ось цей лов
[музика]
неугодних політиків
лов або претензії такі політичні
справи все-таки закінчиться не для того
сьогодні працюю, щоб мені хтось пробачив
якісь надумані претензії чи якимось
здається ми злочини я працював тут
працюють живу тут і мені ніхто сьогодні
не відповів на жодне запитання але моє
наприклад, яку статтю закону я порушив
україни який закон україна назовні який
яку статтю регламенту міського
поради та порушив якусь статтю статуту
міста одеса ​​я порушу приймаючи рішення
або міська рада приймає рішення
все інше це і
знову ж таки хочу щоб це були
виправдувальний вирок незалежно від
того як ніколи не буду звертатися для
щоб приховувати тут мишу всі воювали
ми всі воїни а може бути мені зараз
треба якось пробачити щось за мій
сумлінну роботу, наприклад
не хочу і не звертатимусь і навіть якщо
буде запропоновано і таке я буду
наполягати на тому щоб
продовжилося розслідування та суді було
встановлено правда дякую
пізно